i knew that what i had been ordered to do was wrong.
i said so , i was told to  get on with it.
what else! could i do.
if i'm not done it, someone else  would have done it.
that i have always expected to answer for this.
this deed i never wish to do.
And now, which is the end of the road.
immediately after the second world war.
The allies sort justice for crimes committed against them.
Britain persuade one war crime more than any other.
The investigator  was Frankhmut kanor.
Ex-detective tundra ref policeman.
the crime was murdered.
the worst atrocity against the allied airmen of the entire world war.
the victims  were 50 unarmed prisoners.
Shocking cold blood by gestapo after the great escaped.
The coldest part of the 30 years.
they were smell  on the ground and,
the conditioned outside the brutal.
it was evident to us that Germans knew
that there was the tunnel being built.
they threats the boss several times that day.
And not find it.
the weather was getting worst.
and the things passes were old dated.
of course there we wasted.
and then drew of, a long time they have to do the more again
what we have visible nine months work
On the night of March 24, 1944
200 allied airmen packed it in hut 104
packed it in hut 104
in Nazi's German is most secure prisoner of the  war camp in Sagan
near polish boarder.
they were said to take part in the most
ambitious prison breakout of the second world war.
became to be known as "the great escape"
and did happen because of one man
i'm like'n to hitting the name roger bushell
courageous, b'coz i'm he is one of the
"legendary escaper"
it has been out several times
been set there for a long time, he hadn't appear back
and i heard his name being spoken out of
somebody who might be killed
then i remembered the instinct motivational
and people said the  roger bushell coming back
and there he was she put in-charge of escaping
when felt then the thing was in safe hands
here is a men with extreme abilities
and intelligence  and above all single mindedness
whatever he did he put this whole effort in to it
His real objective  was to achieve this
grand slam. is it were
the big tunnel.
Bushell harnessed the men power and skills of the camp.
600 men spending a year in digging,
forging documents and turning uniforms in civilians curves.
for the organization couldn't make, had be acquired
few German speaker became scroungers
bribing  guards for whatever was needed.
one of them was Dennis Cockrum
fluent in German since it was eighteen
Tannus Fasilaldras then was Keith
then myself
then a young brother four years later
i think
we all knew without any doubt at all, he would be
whealing against the captivity he be like
cage a lion.
Dennis cockrum join the RAF 1940,
and been shot down over the channel
he has been the prisoner over the year
My mother suddenly died
have we didn't knew what to do about telling Dennis
we knew its be a terrible news
for him to have
in those circumstances, but of course
the time went on there was no option but to tell him
and his next letter came back country
and this is the worst day of my life
to news so obviously effected him by strife fully.
that i think would of strenght until resolve
even more so immediate needed it.
his letters than broad ways
i'll be home soon.
home was on the mind  of many that night
Don Curbee Green Bushell's head of security
hadn't seen his wife and young son for more than two years
My Adote darling",
i'm thinking so much of you now
long so heart here
and feel so grateful for your love and tenderness
and so humble
soon i hope
i should be able to make the world paradise  for you
and for collins
"I love you" darling.
what can i say
kisses to you, your Thomas
This my father's letter written on the day of the escape
now that letter is
shorter than the other b'coz he didn't have  much time
but i don't think he probably could
find enough words really to say whole think he wanted to say
he did try.
He was
basically very very gentle person i think
He like cars, he like sailing
And he love my mother.
i mean he really did enormously.
And i think he love me.
i just know that i missed him.
And he was this kind of distance of hero
As we came in we relocated to
particular part of the hut
And order was sit down and
stay there until you were called
people actually remarkably
quiet i think considering what was about to happens
i owe the papers of Yugoslav wood worker,
my colleague  gang with
jemcol sutaro eshkanzic Greek fighter pilot
he had goal set paper of Greek.
.